-You also have an episode --
A Prince-themed episode.
-Oh, yeah.
That was our 100th episode
-100th episode.
You got to dress up like Prince.
-Don't show that belly fat
Look at that right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You --
-Whoo, those pants were tight.
-You knew Prince, right?
-I did, man.
Yeah, I was fortunate enough t
befriend him for a while now
While I lived in New York, you
know, it really got solidified
You know, every time
he would have a show,
he would make sure I was there
And, so, he was performing a
Madison Square Garden,
and near the end of the show
I get a tap on the shoulder,
and it was part
of the security team.
He's like, "Prince wants you t
come up onstage with him."
I was like, "All right."
So I go up onstage.
It's me, Jamie Foxx,
Whoopi Goldberg,
Tavis Smiley, Dr. Cornel West.
And then we head to the
Village Underground
here in New York,
and everybody thought
Prince was going to perform,
but we just sat on our couches
and you watched
everybody else perform.
And it's Prince,
his assistant, and myself.
And Prince leans over
to his assistant...
[ Whispers indistinctly ]
Okay? And his assistant lean
over to me and says,
"Anthony, Prince wants you
to come by the hotel
and have pizza and pasta."
I was like, "Okay. Okay.
It's 2:30 in the morning. Okay."
He leans over and tells
his assistant something else
And Prince leans,
and she gives me the --
I don't know why I
said it like this.
It's a woman who told me tha
Prince said --
So, we go to the Ritz-Carlton.
And when I get there,
there's a bellman
with a key in his hand.
He said, "Mr. Anderson,
Prince is in suite" whatever
And he gives me a key
to the room
and sends me up to the floor
And I open it up, and, you know,
there's an array of people
already in the room.
And I was just like, "Oh, my
This is crazy!"
And I walk in,
I look, and I find Prince.
And Prince was in the back
having a little conversation
with Dr. West and Tavis Smiley
And, you know,
pizza and pasta arrives.
And we eat, and I leave at about
4:30, 5:00 in the morning.
And I'm like, "Yo" --
I'm talking to my baby.
I'm like,
"Baby, can you believe this?
We were just hanging out wit
Prince, eating pizza and pasta!"
-It's also that
it's such a relief,
'cause your fear is that he's --
You know, he was at such a level
that what he would
want to do for fun
would not be a thing
you could grasp,
and the fact that it's
pizza and pasta,
you're like, "I can do that.
-At 3:00 in the morning.
-Yeah.
-It was amazing.
-Did you set a record?
Did you actually
set this golf record?
-Oh, did I set a record
with Prince?
No, but we made a few.
-You -- A Guinness World Record.
-Guinness World Record.
"Guinness Book of
World Records."
Yes, sir.
-And what was the
actual record that you set
-I swung the world's
longest usable golf club
and I hit a ball further tha
anyone in history.
-Wow. And, now, I think --
I want everybody to picture...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want you all to picture wha
the longest usable golf club
could look like.
It's so much longer
than I pictured.
-Yeah.
-Look at that thing.
-It's 47'1" long. It's a driver.
And I did this with Topgol
and Callaway in Vegas.
And I hit the ball over
120 feet.
-Wow.
-And the record was set by
someone who had a club
that was 34'6" long,
and they only hit it
60-some-odd feet.
-Wow! So you might have
this record forever.
-I hope so.
-Yeah.
-And because I have it
right now --
it just missed
the publication --
this will be entered in the book
if nobody breaks it
by the next time the next
publication comes, in November
-That's very exciting.
As like a 9-year-old, that would
have been the highest thin
I could ever achieve.
To be in the "Guinness Book of
World Records," though,
you have made it, my friend.
You have made it.
-But not only that, my son is in
the "Guinness Book
of World Records."
While he was a senior in
high school a couple years ago
he put on the most
T-shirts in 30 seconds.
-Wow!
-Yes.
-What is that?
What is that number?
-I don't know.
I think it was like 19 or 20
19 or 20, maybe 22.
-You are a talented family